déjà faut différencier rodéo et bikelive
Backlife c'est le sang pour moi c'est un
sport c'est vraiment moi je m'entraîne
ça fait 6-7 ans je m'entraîne j'ai
arrêté le travail récemment pour
consacrer à 100% dans mes vidéos et
cetera d'accord mais ça fait 6-7 ans je
m'entraîne je m'efforce à m'entraîner et
derrière ça il y a un réel sport et un
réel art maintenant je comprends que ici
en France ce soit mal vu c'est ça mais
en danger les autres et là je comprends
donc c'est pour ça que je m'efforce avec
un intérêt que j'ai etc de le faire dans
des endroits adéquats parce que
légalement on n'a pas le droit mais
entre je vais dans des champs enfin des
des endroits où il y a personne en fait
mais même comme ça on risque la même
chose que des personnes qui font du
rodéo justement mais justement et puis
bon surtout tu penses aux autres
c'est-à-dire c'est ça aussi ils disent
voilà ça peut mettre en danger euh voilà
sur qu'on les voit sur les routes sur
les trucs c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
Nico toi tu cautionnes ça ou pas je
cautionnes pas du tout c'est en fait moi
je fais je fais pas pareil que que
gringo lui va dans des spots fermés
c'est ça du moins où il y a personne
ouais toi tu fais quoi en fait moi je
vais en ville bon je vais pas dans les
centres dans des centres commerciaux non
plus je suis pas fou mais je vais en
ville mais pourquoi je vais en ville
c'est parce qu'en fait même dans les
spots fermés où il y a personne on est
dans des champs des zones industrielles
où il y a personne il y a absolument
personne et ben en fait on se fait
bouger d'ici par la police c'est c'est
leur boulot c'est il y a pas de problème
il y a pas de problème à ce niveau-là
pas de différencier le problème c'est où
on met des règles claires exactement il
y a pas d'alternative et en fait pas de
problème mais derrière il faudrait des
alternatives des endroits où c'est
structuré de la sécurité en fait est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas faire
comme le karting parce qu'on pourrait
pas faire des pistes
dédié au Rodeo et là comme ça il y a
plus de rodéo bien sûr exactement il y a
le circuit Carole c'est la première fois
depuis plus de 15 ans c'est la première
fois ça s'est passé il y a trois mois où
ils ont accepté de faire des sessions
ouvertes à la back life à la moto donc
un autre sport et c'est la première fois
parce que là on voit on en parle il y a
des je vous le dis il y a des il y a des
citoyens qui sont qui vivent la peur au
ventre c'est
c'est c'est vraiment ça c'est une
minorité c'est peut-être 1%, c'est
maintenant vous allez dans des spots
fermés donc des zones industriels le
dimanche là où il y a rien du tout il y
a juste des mecs qui font de la moto
vous y allez il y a 100 personnes mais
par contre vous allez dans les villes ou
quoi que ce soit vous croisez jamais de
moto ça arrive jamais ça arrive une fois
tous les 100 ans et malheureusement il y
a des quartiers il y a des quartiers
deux enfants 10 et 11 ans blessés à
Rennes une dame de 78 ans qui a été
grièvement blessée laissée pour morte en
2020 à Toulouse une femme qui a été tué
à cause d'un rodéo pareil 77 ans
donc c'est pas une fois tous les 5 ans
c'est qu'il y en a et qu'il y a donc des
accidents donc moi je suis d'accord
monsieur vous avez raison visiblement
c'est quelque chose qui existe et qui
fait plaisir donc trouvons des solutions
et encadrants
mais le problème c'est que moi en fait
je me suis fait saisir une moto que j'ai
acheté 7000 euros que je travaille tous
les jours de la semaine pour attendre le
weekend en fer je me suis fait saisir ma
moto
j'étais dans un spot fermé et en fait le
problème c'est qu'on a pas le droit et
c'est en fait c'est qualifié de l'urbain
c'est exactement la même chose que si on
allait en ville et bah du coup bah moi
je vais pas rester sur un spot ou la
police ils peuvent venir me tuer
facilement et prendre ma moto
on ouvre une piste bah à circuit Carole
de toutes les sessions j'y étais j'ai
payé j'ai payé 50 € pour 3 heures de
session je les paye moi je veux pas
mettre des gens manger je veux pas
mettre mon futur enfant ou une
grand-mère qui traverse la route moi je
vais juste faire de la moto j'ai envie
j'ai envie d'apprendre j'ai envie
d'apprendre de nouvelles techniques
parce que